we know who they are they short the
market they short the dollar and when
things look unstable or the situation
gets a little rocky here at home they
look for the exits
maybe they move their money or their
businesses offshore because they think
America has seen her best days but truly
smart people including smart Democrats
know that betting against America has
always been a losing proposition even
during our darkest hours the civil war
the Great Depression
at a recent Berkshire Hathaway
shareholders Buffett who's no fan of
Donald Trump discussed America's past
and future trials yeah this testing
period and people really lost faith to
some degree they just didn't see the
potential of what America could do and
we found that nothing to stop America
when you get right down to it it may
have been tested again and the Great
Depression and it may be tested now to
some degree in the end the answer is
never bet against America
and it shouldn't surprise you any of you
that Warren Buffett is a hell of a lot
smarter than left-wing economists who've
been predicting doomsday scenarios for
the US economy since Kovan well today
the Dow jumped 500 points almost closing
above 25,000 consumer confidence rising
investors across the board are seeing
light at the end of the tunnel in Texas
Georgia South Carolina Utah Florida
Alabama Mississippi all run by a pretty
conservative governor's well you see
their life is finally getting back to
normal even California's lockdown lover
Gavin Newsom he's under pressure from
lawsuits from small business owners and
people in the faith community and he has
had to ease up also Los Angeles County
officials initially suggested the
lockdown could last through the summer
but after massive backlash across the
board
LA County is aiming to now reopen on
July 4th and churches are opening at 25
percent capacity starting tomorrow and
as for those blue state governors that
just won't accept yes for an answer
well don't believe for a second they're
fraudulent justifications that it's all
for your own safety you know they always
say that when they're taking away your
constitutional rights but it's becoming
more obvious by the day that these
power-hungry governors and radical
mayor's are endangering their state's
futures and will eventually see their
state's left behind
now it's horrific enough that Andrew
Cuomo ended up creating death traps in
New York's elderly facilities but now
his slow roll to reopen is doing untold
damage to his state going forward the
Washington Post wrote this piece over
the weekend they ran it about how the
Kovich shutdown has been the straw that
broke the camel's back for New York more
residents now are reporting being so fed
up with life in the big la a Big Apple
that they're relocating to places where
they can actually have a decent standard
of living and Cuomo wants taxpayers in
Florida and
Texas and beyond to bail him out none of
these lockdown liberals should get a
penny more and bailout money so long as
they continue this lockdown stuff
because the longer they stay lack
lockdown and you have all these other
onerous and unnecessary restrictions in
place the more difficult the more
expensive and I'd say the more dangerous
it becomes for their state's a longer
any kind of recovery will be given that
we now know that the virus is a lot less
deadly than originally thought and that
it's most dangerous to the confined
elderly there's no good reason to keep
any part of the country completely
closed unless that is you don't want
America to recover at least while Trump
is president an article in political you
may have heard of it it reported over
the weekend that Democrats are privately
freaking out yes you heard that right
that the American economy will be in a
massive recovery mode come the fall
check this out this is my big worry set
a former Obama White House official
who's still close to the former
president asked about the level of
concern among top party officials he
said it's hi hi hi hi now how do you
describe this except to say that
Democrats see their only serious path to
victory hinging on your despair deep
down it seems like they're rooting
against life getting better for American
families the rooting for Americans to
remain unemployed can you believe that
anyone or for schools to say closed now
long after we flattened the curve they
issue these grim warnings of a second
wave a third wave that could come next
month it could come in September it
could be worse more people that I mean
or the super spreader phenomenon or you
really have to have 18-feet social
distancing or 30 feet or sneeze spreads
40 feet I mean every minute of every day
they have to push the panic button to
scare you back into your homes they
shame people who don't bow down to their
new rules but in the end
most of these people seeking to control
your behavior don't apply the rules to
themselves they never do do they will
share the biggest offenders with you in
just a moment
now what worries these hypocrites is not
the dire situation they created in their
own States they're worried about the
possibility of your state's economic
recovery Trump could be poised to
benefit from the dramatic numbers
produced during the partial rebound
phrase that is likely to coincide with
the four months before November that
realization has many Democrats spooked
now let that sink in for a moment where
you and I are spooked about the idea of
living like masked zombies waiting for
government checks for this foreseeable
future the Democrats are spooked by the
idea that things are getting better
in March Biden's campaign Pelosi Schumer
the whole gang were betting that the
virus would [ __ ] the economy right
through the election the only way that
that happens now though is if enough
blue state governors make love life
unlivable for the ninety nine point nine
nine percent of Americans who survive
this virus that's a pathetic
anti-science sicko campaign strategy but
let him make that bet America will not
allow this crisis to beget a waste and
that's the angle